it's a big night tonight who are you
excited
well snoop dogg who is right next to me
uh j-lo so many people some days um
snoop sophia wants to sleep oh oh oh oh
excuse me they're way too cool for me
i'm just going to be photobombing this
photo behind them there's like can you
please say hello
okay we're just talking over here okay
the other night you were hanging out
with miss celina gomez what was it like
to get back oh it was great she's the
sweetest thing and you know she's
amazing we were in new york and she just
done snl and she's just always rooting
for her
how did that friendship come to be uh
mutual friends mutual friends yeah well
you're just your music so good lately
what are you loving about you know you
had that moment of getting that album
out what has it been like to see the
response so emotional and exciting and
beautiful and uh really fulfilling
you and dove by the way both crushing
the pop girl game right now do you like
play songs for each other or give each
other advice honestly we hadn't seen
each other in a really long time until
about a week or two ago when we went to
the the cameron boy scala together and
it was really nice to kind of reconnect
and i am so proud of her and all that
she's doing so it's yeah it was nice you
know the descendants crew getting back
together for that how emotional is that
it's so cool that you guys continue to
support absolutely it was very emotional
you know we hadn't all been together
since we shot the last movie with cam
and um it was an emotional night but it
was a really beautiful night true to
cam's spirit and what his mom and his
dad are doing um so it was it was
special
yeah
tonight is a night for we've got
jennifer lopez getting the generation
award why is she so deserving of that
moniker i mean she's an icon she has
done
everything from movies to tv to music to
fashion to philanthropist the example
that she sets for girls everywhere that
nothing is impossible is really
something to aspire to and i've always
been a huge fan and i can't wait to see
her today staring at the earrings these
earrings aren't they beautiful
um that's a good question
but i loved them uh tb i will tell you
in a second i will find out are they the
kind that come with a security guard
uh potentially yes
we ask everybody what's one secret about
the outfit yeah yeah oh one secret about
the outfit today
it came that it just finished like they
had to essentially sew it on me right
before we came in but that happens a lot
like the little final touches
yeah you're sewed in i'll let you go
good to see you too
[Music]